انا في بيت صباح الخير عليكم صباح الخير
يا سهام صباح الخير يا نادين
ده حقيقي انا هنا في مع اسره كريمه
مستضيفاني عايزه بس اقول لكم احنا فعلا من
كم يوم في اواخر اكتوبر وصلنا ل 104 مليون
نسمه مقارنه
فبراير الماضي كونا 103 مليون نسمه يعني
احنا زادتنا مليون في سبع شهور تقريبا اا
رغم مجهودات الدوله اللي بتعملها لتنظيم
الاسره والحملات اللي بتروح القرى والنجوع
ولكن عندنا مشكله في مصر العادات
والتقاليد المترسخه عند الاسره المصريه
يمكن بيبقى همم صعب شويه تغييرها او جايز
الاجيال الجديده انا شايفه دلوقتي هتبتدي
تغيرها وعندنا
من المناصرها
انا بحب العيله الكبيره بحبك
[ضحك]
هم اثنين زي ما يجوا ولا دين ماشي بنتين
ماشي ولد وبنت ماشي انا عن نفسي كان نفسي
في توام مره واحده يعني
بس
الحمد لله يعني احنا اكتفينا بهم وغيرنا
فكره بقى ايه لا لازم تخاوي البنت لازم
تجيبي لها اخ يبقى سندكي اااه
وغير الظن بقى
من اخواتي من صحابي من حماتي عايزين ايه
بقى بيقولوا لك ايه
[موسيقى]
لا اثنين مش كفايه مش ناويه تجيبي بيبي
تاني على طول على طول كده احنا ولا اي
حاجه ههه
لا هم اثنين يعني الحمد لله ربنا يبارك لي
فيهم واعرف ايه اربيهم كويس
اصلا
الاولاد اه
[ضحك]
ايه بقى انت كنت عايزين تلاته ولا انت
مخططتيش ولا
ما كناش مرتبين للصراحه بس هو عاوز بنت بس
انا كده حلوه قوي بنات ثانيه و عيال ثاني
لا عشان بصراحه
من اهل انك تخلفي اكثر لا لا مش حبنا اجيب
عيال كثير
هي جايبه جايبه كثير بس هي قالت لي لا
كفايه كده لان انا تعبانه
في ناس تعرفيهم في مثلا انتم همم انتم
يعني في نفس الاسره هل دخلته منافسه بقى
لي ساعات
في عندكم
بنات كثير لا مش عايزين بنات عايزين صبيان
يخشو سباق مين هيبقى
بنات اكثر لغايه لما
طيب انا سؤال اخير هل قصه وصلنا ل 8 مليار
نسمه في العالم هل انتم قلقانين على
مستقبل الاولاد هل انتم بتفكروا كده اه
طبعا
في التعليم في اللبس في حاجات كثير فطبعا
قلقانين عليهم
تمام شكرا جزيلا يبدو ان احنا على مشارف
تغيير كبير في المجتمع المصري الشباب
الجديد يعني مش عايز عيله كبيره الان من
مستقبل جايز وشكرا يا سهام شكرا نادين رغم
كل الازمات ما زالت البشريه تتكاثر حياه
تنجب حياه